given how set time out works when past a
function reference what would you expect
to happen when you pass in a method that
was first looked up as a property of an
object notice that we're using dot
notation to find the method at the
moment we go looking for it to pass it
in to set timeout again let's start by
considering how we expect the positional
parameters to work as before they're
bound to undefined since no values were
passed in in between the parentheses on
the line where we call the callback
furthermore the set timeout function
wasn't passed any of the color values
that might have been passed to the
callback and so the body of set timeout
wouldn't have any way of knowing what
values you wanted passed in the next
question is what will get bound to the
parameter this hint remember where we
have to look to determine the binding
for the parameter this it isn't in the
function definition nor is it where the
function is looked up on the object the
important moment is where the function
is actually invoked generally people
find it tempting to imagine that since
we did a property look up on the red
object perhaps that lookup event would
have some bearing on the keyword this
inside the function but this moment is
irrelevant since only the moment of call
time influences how the parameter this
will get bound just as in the previous
example where we passed in FN instead of
our dot method the last line of set
timeout is still a free function
invocation and not a method invocation
with a dot therefore this would still be
bound to its default value the global
object